bonjour cd libourne pour brut mon père
me dépose en camion à l'entrée de paris
qui était une ville interdite pour moi
puisque le 38 tonnes de mon papa ne
pouvait pas rentrer dans paris
donc il me dépose porte de vincennes
avec un sac à dos et une guitare et les
économies de ma maman qui représentait à
l'époque une vie d'un d'économie d'une
femme de ménage soit 1250 euros
c'est peu d'abord je suis au cours simon
que je n'arrive pas à payer donc ils me
font gratuitement je remercie encore le
cours simon de m'avoir offert les cours
j'ai pas payer les cours parce que ils
étaient contents a trouvé bon donc
c'était bon signe
j'ai été d'abord dessinateur pendant
pendant deux ans et demi le storyboarder
je commençais à très bien gagner ma vie
ça m'a sorti de la merde et je me suis
remis dedans parce que j'ai tout arrêté
pour les tracteurs faire de la scène
voilà parce que j'ai croisé quelqu'un
qui était une ancienne du cours simon
qui m'a dit alors tu es acteur j'ai dit
maintenant je suis dessinateur
enfin si vous êtes acteur c'est toi si
oui tu as raison j'arrête demain j'ai
arrêté le lendemain à 2008 c'est l'année
de la sortie de bienvenue chez les
ch'tis et là c'est la claque
il faut savoir que ce matin là ce
mercredi là je me réveille
j'ai une angoisse c'est qu'il fasse beau
et que les gens aillent pas au cinéma
c'est un film qui a marché sur toutes
les générations et les gens est ce que
t'es dingue c'est que je vais des gens
qui allaient au cinéma qui était pas
allé depuis des années quoi des années
des années et on me dit en nombre la td
des anecdotes tous les gens allaient
dans le cinéma disait où l ouvreuse
voudrait une place au balcon on n'y a
plus de mal quand j'appuie la plus
dangereuse ya plus de balles quand j'ai
plein d'anecdotes comme ça et des
moments dingues j'en suis conscient on
me téléphone je décroche on me dit en
refusant à émettre soit mais c'est quoi
au smi/sli louis smith will smith a
varié au bénin il m'a dit ça l'univers
mois était que charlize theron qui
faisait 50 centimètres de pluie et un
peu à belhout et c'était drôle
voilà j'ai vécu des trucs assez donne
quoi je me pensais à chaque fois et donc
avec jérôme seydoux on a monté un fonds
fondation qui s'appelle le ch'ti fonds
et
depuis bienvenue chez les ch'tis toutes
les pros tous les produits dérivés de
mes films bon à cette association
toujours dans la tête que j'aurais pu je
pourrais j'aurais pu être enfin il était
un peu enfin j'ai pas été à la rue
devrait pas vécu dans la rue mais parce
que j'ai réussi à me démerder à méditer
quand on est interdit bancaire et que on
vit à droite à gauche chez des gens des
copains qui voudraient qu'ils hébergent
jusqu'à un certain point nous avons bien
maintenant il faut que tu t'en as il
faut que tu trouves un dans d'autres
endroits on est quand même dans un
moment de précarité assez fort et ça va
ça peut aller très vite notamment à
dunkerque on a en a eu
grâce à monsieur delbarre un terrain
communal pour construire un immeuble et
faire des maisons une maison pour pour
sdf finances qui n'en étaient plus donc
je suis allé à l'inauguration j'ai
accepté d'aller à une opération de cette
maison de cette maison qui était un
moment absolument dingue de ma vie en
fin de ma carrière et de ma vie surtout
de mon fait visiter cet endroit écoute
ses chambres et ses pièces communes et
ça et ils m'ont il m'avait écrit des
poèmes et quand ils m'ont lu ses poèmes
je vous assure que ça a été un des
moments les plus émouvants de demain de
ma vie voilà c'est tout ça ça fait
partie des moments de vie fort